I almost feel like they intentionally
sabotaged Afghanistan to guarantee their
ability to reinvade later if they want
to it sure looks like that I had there's
a congressman Warren Davidson who's been
like a real hero saying we got to get
our guys out no matter what and I asked
him is this just gross incompetence the
way we got out of Afghanistan or was it
purposeful
and and he in a very political way said
I don't see how it can't have been
purposeful so that the lesson is don't
ever get out of anything ever again
because it it doesn't work and you have
to wonder why they would abandon Bagram
Air Force base without notifying
security forces in the country why they
cut all air air support Logistics
there's no way it wasn't attention why
they left all that equipment and didn't
decommission it with Nano thermite like
they didn't melt the machines before
they just left they just signed and and
they were purposely blocking private
efforts they had they had Transportation
they had people and all the state
department had to say was do it and they
blocked it